you know a lot of people want to know
what foods should you be focused on to
burn the most fat or to lose the most
weight so instead of getting into the
details of a diet i wanted to just focus
in on the foods and the key foods that
have the
least effect
on insulin okay because
insulin is a hormone that even in tiny
amounts will block your ability to lose
weight insulin is the hormone that
converts
the carbs that you eat
into actual fat so it is the fat
making hormone and so if we compile the
list of all the foods that have the
least effect on insulin you can have the
best list
to help you lose the most weight now the
only thing i want to bring up with this
list is uh quantity of protein if you're
doing high levels of protein that can
potentially slow you down because that
can then stimulate insulin but if you're
having a moderate amount of protein on
this plan you're going to do quite well
in fact if you keep your protein around
around seven grams maybe eight grams per
meal uh you're going to be doing very
very well and of course if you really
want to be successful you really won't
only want to do
two meals per day
or even one meal a day all right let's
start with the proteins okay so we have
all these proteins have less than one
gram or zero grams of carbohydrates okay
so
eggs beef lamb chicken pork veal duck
hot dog sausage deli meat organ meats
dried meats
and pork rinds which is a collagen but
also realize that you have to read the
ingredients because some of these foods
like even deli meats um sausage hot dogs
can have hidden sugars like dextrose uh
even high fructose corn syrup and even
the dried meats can have like beet sugar
so you want to avoid meats with sugar
all right so that's the protein list and
of course tea coffee and water have no
carbohydrates so you don't worry about
that and then you have apple cider
vinegar okay zero carbohydrates
seasonings
mustard great thing to put on your meat
no carbs or less than even a half a gram
of carb and then we have monk fruit
stevia and erythritol all have zero
carbohydrates uh lemon lime
very very small amount of carbs it's
less than one which is insignificant now
there are two other things that i want
to talk about in relationship to insulin
okay
pure fat has no effect on insulin now if
something is combined with a carb it's
going to have more effect on insulin but
if you have a pure fat it's going to
have no effect on insulin so
butter ghee
talo lard coconut oil olive oil mct oil
whole cream
all are pretty much pure fats so those
are not going to have an effect
on your insulin despite having a lot of
calories and so these fats will turn
into energy now of course there's always
a limitation of matter if you consume
an ungodly amount of this
yeah potentially it can turn into fat
for sure but if at the same time you're
not consuming any carbohydrates and
you're doing a high fat diet that fat is
going to turn into energy and that is
because you primed the pump you
converted your body over into ketosis so
now it's no longer running on glucose
so when you feed the fat it turns that
into ketones if you still had
carbohydrates with fat
you wouldn't have this conversion and
you wouldn't be able to burn that fat
too effectively in fact a lot of fat
will be stored as fat i want to mention
one thing about this because
sometimes you'll see
in certain studies it'll say my study
showed that mice consuming a high
fat diet
caused
increased weight gain it caused diabetes
insulin resistance and then you actually
read the study for yourself and you find
out
the high fat
diet that these mice were on
were not just a high fat diet notice
they did not mention
ketogenic diet notice they didn't
mention a low carb diet they just
mentioned a high fat diet and these high
fat diets that they feed mice are also a
high carbohydrate diet their
carbohydrates that they put in this high
fat diet are roughly about 36 percent
carbohydrates so it's a high carb high
fat diet so that right there invalidates
the whole study all right mayonnaise
now
obviously it doesn't have any carbs but
a lot of times it has soy oil or canola
oil or cottonseed oil
you want to avoid those oils because
they're highly inflammatory
now avocados do have a good amount of
fat they have a good amount of fiber
they have some carbohydrate but they're
a really good
fat
vegetable
and a also a good fat oil that you can
use in your cooking but avocados will
not cause you to gain weight mct oil is
a pure fat will not trigger insulin in
fact it converts to ketones very very
efficiently all right let's move to the
next section of this list
there is one carbohydrate that has zero
effect on insulin okay
that is fiber
so when we take the total carb and we
minus the fiber we get our net carbs and
that's what we're looking at when we're
calculating this plan we want something
to be very very low net carb so this
next list
are all carbohydrates that have
very low amounts of carbs and a good
amount of fiber so when we deduct that
we come out with a very very small
amount of carbohydrates so olives less
than one gram of carbohydrate
insignificant spinach 1.4 grams net carb
now this is all just one cup as we go
down the list okay one cup of mushroom
that's one gram net carb sprouts one cup
one gram net carbs celery that's one
this is one stalk not a cup it's less
than one gram it's point nine grams uh
net carb cucumber one cup 2.5 grams
arugula one cup
.36 grams net carb that's like one third
of a cup arugula is a great vegetable
it's cruciferous and it's very very low
in carb it'll help you lose weight
lettuce one cup
point six grams net carb okay
this is why i recommend you know seven
to ten cups of vegetables because the
carbs are so low you don't have to count
the carbs as your any calculation of
your keto plan and very high in fiber
with a lot of potassium
bok choy one cup 2.4 grams net carb a
very small amount water crest one cup .3
grams net carb out of all the leafy
greens i think watercress are the least
amount of net carbs okay asparagus one
cup 2.3 grams net carb
one large pickle
0.5 grams net carb it's like a half a
gram insignificant zucchini one cup 2.3
grams net carb
cauliflower one cup
3.1 grams of net carb now if you're on
the ketogenic plan you're allowed
you know up to 50 grams of carbs okay
per day so we're talking about one or
two maybe potentially three grams of
carb
it's insignificant all right let's talk
about cheese one ounce of gouda cheese
less than one gram of net carb
blue cheese .7 grams net carb cream
cheese .1 gram net carb insignificant
parmesan cheese .7 grams net carb in
brie cheese 0.7 gram of net carb
insignificant all right here's some
other ideas you can do a cheese wrap and
you can put make your uh your like your
sandwiches with your meat and your
lettuce and just wrap it with cheese in
these cheese wraps that you can get at
the store now it's like one gram of net
carb so
insignificant then you have konjac
noodles one bag is one gram you can cook
with this as your pasta noodle it's not
too bad but there's
insignificant amount of carbohydrates
compared to
pasta which is off the charts
all right then we have slim rice which
is a
looks like rice and it's from the konjac
plant
and you can put some vegetables in it
you should definitely try that one it's
pretty cool another thing i want to
mention with the bread
there's so many people that just cannot
give up bread
and so there's a great recipe it's
simple it's called cloud bread
zero carbohydrate okay you just mix eggs
cream cheese and cream of tartar i'll
put the recipe down below
it makes bread i mean it looks like
bread it tastes like bread you can put
stuff in it it's quite amazing and then
we have nox jello okay
great for kids you can maybe put some
stevia that has different flavors they
have lemon and raspberry and strawberry
different flavors you can check that out
but that has zero grams of carbohydrate
so this is your list if you wanted to
lose weight and you wanted to keep it
really simple
just type out this list
and you're going to lose a ton of weight
but sooner or later you're going to want
the details of exactly how to do healthy
keto intermittent fasting and for that
check out my playlist right here